hi there today we're looking at dream to
control learning behaviors by latent
imagination by Doniger Hoffner Timothy
Lilly corrupt Timmy sorry Jimmy ba and
Mohammed neuro Z this is a reinforcement
learning paper that iterates on a kind
of a series of previous papers where the
goal is to learn a policy in this case
they want to learn policies for these
kind of continuous control tasks so
these um physics-based robots these
hopper or Walker types of tasks where
you have to control this this robot
these joints in order to move forward
and so the the goal is that you have
multiple observations as you do in in
reinforcement learning and from each
observation you need to somehow come up
with an action of what to do and then
that will give you the next observation
as well as a reward a reward for you
know if you if your goal is to move this
spider
maybe the reward is proportional to how
far you move so your goal is to collect
the maximum reward which would mean you
have to move the spider as far as
possible simply by doing the correct
actions the goal of this paper now is to
to do this by learning how the by
learning to sort of plan ahead in this
latent space so as you can see here the
way they do it is they take the
observation and they feed it through an
encoder now you can think of this as
maybe a convolutional neural network or
something anything that can work that
can take an image as an input and give
you a hidden representation so now this
here is the hidden representation from
this hidden repairs
patien you can determine what the next
action is going to be and then you get a
new observation and then again you can
feed that along with the last hidden
state into a new hidden state so this
this is already on previous previous
models do this a lot right you encode
your observation and you have a sort of
an let's say a recurrent neural network
that incorporates all of the
observations into a hidden state along
with the actions you take and then you
always decide on a next action to do so
what does this model do differently this
model wants to do this all in hidden
space so what this model wants to do is
it wants to say okay I am here I have
this observation now my encoder tells me
that this is going to give me this
hidden state and now what it wants to do
is it wants to take in the action that
is doing and without seeing the next
observation right
it wants to predict it already wants to
say well if I am here and I do this
action what might the action be the
action might be to put the joystick to
the right it will learn the hidden state
corresponding to the spider being a bit
more to the right right so this is a bit
more to the right than it is right now
and it will you do so a number of time
steps into the future
and it will kind of learn from its own
imagination so this this is what um it
will imagine into the future how the
hidden states look and then it will
learn from that instead of having to
really do the actions in the real world
now we've already looked at a number of
papers including something like mu zero
or I 2a or something like this this now
is only is slightly different so you can
see
so what what's different here what is
different is in new 0 we had this we use
this latent model in order to plan ahead
like in order to do our decision tree
planning ahead and so on this model
doesn't do this this model still wants
to come up with a single policy where
you encode your state right this is on
the right is the final result you encode
your state gets you to a hidden
representation and then from that you
determine what your actions going to be
and you have your next state and so on
so the final goal is simply going to be
a policy like a single-shot policy
without any Monte Carlo tree expansion
and so on but what it wants to do is it
wants to learn this policy not by
interacting in the real world like here
on the left but actually by interacting
only in the dream world right here so
the crucial part if you want to learn
from your dreams right is to make sure
that your dreams are an accurate
representation of the of the real world
right
we already saw this in a paper called
world models by jurgen schmidhuber i
believe and in that paper what they did
was they first collected experience such
like experience like this one and then
they learned from the one observation to
predict the next ones and idle or to
predict the next hidden states right
they did so by basically moving in the
world at random so they have this little
spider thingy and they just do random
movements right they randomly move
around and thus they collect these
trajectories and then they learn from
the random trajectories the difference
that this paper does is
it does these steps iteratively so it
will not learn from random policy but it
will actually first
yeah it'll start out learning this
random learning a good policy for its
environment model then acting going back
and using that policy in order to learn
a better environment model and then
again learn using the better environment
model in order to learn a better policy
if this wasn't clear enough we'll jump
to the algorithm the algorithm isn't
actually too too complicated as I said
it's it's I think it's a relatively
minor iteration on previous research but
it appears to work and it works in these
kind of continuous control tasks so you
see you have three models here that you
need to learn and that's what you see
over here there is representation
transition and reward and you'll see
they all have the same parameters so
that gives you an indication that these
things are a single model now what are
what is the model representation
transition and reward so let me this
this is the the thing on the left here
in the in this part of the algorithm you
assume that you have a policy you
already know what action you do or you
can even assume that you have some
experience right you have your agent is
running with a given policy and you
simply collect that and now you're
trying to learn so let me scratch all of
this what do you have given given is the
observation sequence
and the actions you took right and the
rewards you got that's also given so
each action gives you reward right so
these things are are given provided to
you
and now what do you want to learn you
want to learn a representation and the
transition and let's say a reward so you
also want to predict the next reward
this thing this thing right
so as we already said you can do this by
encoding the state using for example a
CN N and then using an LST M in order to
incorporate this over time so what you
learn is the transition from one hidden
state to the next hidden state and you
also learn the how the observation goes
into the hidden state and thirdly you
learn that if I'm in this hidden state
and I take this particular action I will
get this reward in the future all right
you can learn this from just a set of
precomputed or from a set of experience
that you have in your let's say your
replay buffer alright this is one model
and you learn this here in this first
step in this called dynamics learning
section right so you see while not
converged so you do dynamics learning
you draw data sequences from your
experience right then you compute the
model States these are the hidden States
and then you you update this parameter
theta using representation learning
now they don't really specify what
representation learning is but they do
give examples of what you can do I think
their point is whatever you need to do
in order to learn these representation
and one example is actually drawn here
one example is you can learn a model
that reconstructs the next state or
actually sorry reconstructs the same
state so you can learn a model that
predicts so if you give the observation
as an input it goes through the hidden
state you can learn a decoder that
reconstructs that observation this is
usually done in in things like
variational auto-encoders in order to
produce generative models so the this
part here would be the generator and
that would be kind of the thing of
interest if you are doing a variational
auto encoder but of course here our
quantity of interest is this there's
some encoder model because we want a
good representation of the state and but
but it it comes down to the same thing
if you can learn a model that learns to
accurately reconstruct the observation
then your representation here in the
middle is probably an informative one
right because you learn the same model
across multiple observations that means
it can accurately encode what makes one
observation different from another one
right so this is how you learn the theta
parameters right now
the other models here are the action and
the value parameters and this is here in
the step called behavior learning so in
the behavior learning what they say is
imagine trajectories from each of the
states that you have so what you're
going to do is from each of the
observations here
you're going to obtain the hidden states
right this these hidden states now from
each of the hidden states here so here
is an observation from its hidden state
you're going to use the model that you
learned here through the LST M sorry
well this is terrible
through the LST M you're going to use
that model to imagine future
trajectories right of hidden States so
you have given sorry given or now is the
observation here and the hidden state
and you're going to imagine future
hidden States you're also going to
imagine future rewards right and you are
going to use your your policy kind of -
you're going to use your policy in order
to determine which actions you're going
to take right and the ultimate goal here
is to learn a good policy so a policy
that will give you better rewards in the
future as you would do so this is
regular reinforcement learning except
that the difference is in regular
reinforcement learning I have my
observation I encode it and then I
determine what action I want to take
then I feed that action back into the
environment which would give me the next
observation and then I'd use that to
determine maybe in conjunction with the
last hidden state the next action in
this thing since we learned a dynamics
model of the hidden States we can simply
determine the action and then simply
compute what the probable next hidden
state is going to be and then use that
to determine an action again and so on
so there's no need to go through the
environment which means potentially we
can learn much much faster without
having to expensively interact with the
environment
so and that allows us to basically also
these models here they might be quite
large so our back prop now only needs to
happen through this path basically if we
want to or through through this path
here in case we have discrete actions
yes so that's in that will be the
dynamics learning it's down here and
that's agency we predict the rewards and
the values and compute value estimates
and then we update these parameters
using so what we have is here a value
function see the value function is
dependent on this sigh here and this we
update using a gradient of its output
minus the true value so this this here
is an estimate of the value and as you
know a value function is supposed to
tell you the complete future we reward
given a state right and it's important
for us that we have a function that can
estimate that because of course then we
can take actions if we can make this
function go high and this is an accurate
function that means we get a lot of
reward in the future right so it's
important to learn this function and
here you can see we adjusted into the
direction of matching this quantity
better now we'll get to this quantity in
a second you can also see we update this
parameter which is the action model so
here you see that the action model
depends on this this is this is our
policy right this thing here determines
which action we take and we update it
into the direction this is a gradient
with respect to this value function
right so we train the policy to maximize
the value
which is all the future rewards that we
get of course we can do this because we
can now back propagate through all of
these time steps because we have this we
have this transition model we can back
propagate through all of this which is
pretty cool I think in my opinion the
the kind of workhorse of this paper
might be this quantity here so what how
exactly do you compute the value of a
state especially in this continuous
control tasks you sometimes have a lot
of steps so this these trajectories
might be pretty long and they might be
longer than what you can back propagate
here reasonably from from time step to
time step right even an LS TM might only
be able to back drop through let's say a
couple of dozen or maybe a few hundred
steps in time and maybe you have longer
trajectories here so it's pretty I think
the this value estimate here is a main
component of extending that range so
they say this is according to equation
six and this is what it what it does
again this is my opinion that this here
is kind of the workhorse of the of the
method so it's a three step process
actually it's pretty pretty heavy so you
see this is the quantity they estimate
with the value function it is it is set
between an average over so H is the time
horizon right that you are looking for
it is set between these two things
across the sum over the time horizon now
each of those things again here is a sum
over this tau
this towel here which is this Tao and
the and H minus 1 and H here is the
minimum of tapas K and topless arises so
this goes this looks this this quantity
looks K steps into the future so for
each step to the horizon we look K steps
into the future and and for each step we
look into the future we sum again across
these quantities here and these
quantities here what is that it's a
mixture of the reward you get in that
particular step plus your own your
estimate of the value function at the at
the horizon step discounted by that so
it's pretty so if you imagine you have
like a time number of steps that you
took and each time you get a reward
right this is a very complicated way of
summing of going into the future
summing up the rewards going more steps
summing up the rewards again in
different fashion and then mixing these
these individual quantities so this one
this one this one that you got from
accumulating all of these in a weird
fashion and that allows you to look way
beyond especially you see here your
estimate of the value function will
actually include your own value function
that again will probably looks into the
future
so what you accumulate from the last
step in your time horizon already
includes information from all the future
steps because you take your own value
estimate into account this is I think
it's very convoluted but again I think
this this is um
this complicated value estimate allows
you to to to have a better value
estimate for into the future they do
show some some kind of samples here of
what they can do I haven't found any
videos of it unfortunately but it
appears to work pretty well they have a
discussion of different representation
learning methods and different
experiments and ablations and so on so
invite you to look at this paper and I
hope this was somewhat clear but I